the local kid from denver it's a dream
come true the 28 year old making his
fifth start he was uh spending some time
on the il out of spring training
he had a strained left shoulder
and um in his career coors field 52
games 49 it starts 19 and 16. a
respectable era at 4.4
meyers
sends this out to shallow right center
it'll fall for a base hit machado is
headed for third base
and the padres have runners at the
corners with two down
0-1 on grisham
and a ground ball diving play by cj crow
that saved
boy just what kyle freeland needed
fine play by the big first baseman
the padres making start number 14 in a
padres uniform is blake snell and blake
snell at coors for his career want to
know
only
10 innings but still only two earned
runs a nice 1.801
and that is another hit down the third
base line will rymel go for two of
course he will throw is high
and he's got himself a double
how much fun is he to watch
tapia takes third base and trevor story
coming up
this is down there
alive inside out one-nothing colorado
and story galloping towards second he'll
have a double and for trevor that is rbi
number
400 in his career
cj crone upright stance to begin as
snell stares in
and this is hammered to deep left center
field way back
and the rockies have a three nothing
first inning lead how about that a b
here's the three and one fuentes swings
he hits it well out towards center but
grisham able to track it down and a
little bit over towards left center he
makes a catch on a sinking line drive a
couple of hard hit outs in the first
inning but the rockies get three on
three extra base hits couple of doubles
and a two run homer from cj crone he has
hit very nicely against left-handed
pitching this year and the first from
freeland is hit hard the other way
that'll get on through into right center
field for a base hit one out single ha
kim
and all ready for the padres three hits
against freeland looking to cash in in
the run column now
diving stop fuentes across the diamond
out of first
how good was that
webster rivas thought he had extra bases
joshua fuentes diving stopping from his
knees throws out rivas and that's why
he's one of the leaders at third base
and defensive run saved what a diving
play near the line
and a chop off the plate freeland grabs
it he'll flip it to first
and that takes care of san diego in the
second
two shutout innings for kyle freeland
one down here in the third inning for
fernando tatis jr
fly ball
deep left field
crushed
fernando tatis junior connects on a 21st
home run of the year and the padres are
on the board emphatically don't throw it
there fernando unloaded on this pitch
line to center field in a ringing single
for manny machado some good contact here
in this third inning against kyle
freeland another 2-2 swing and a
miss
and myers will
go down on the strikeout the ball got
behind elias diaz so down to second
goes machado
grounded out to first base in the first
inning goal for one
fly ball
headed out to deep left field back goes
toppy at the wall that ball is gone
two run home run for trent grisham his
second of the series and with one swing
of the bat the padres have tied the
score three to three as that deficit has
been taken care of for blake snell after
a three-run first inning for the rockies
from left field the throw will be in
time
fernando tati's jr from short left gets
it there and daz is retired for the
first out of the third
two down for brendan rodgers flight out
to right field in the first inning go
for one pitch swung on and blooped up
the middle that's going to be down and
the base hit into center field around
third and scoring is trevor story and
brendan rogers got enough on it to
deliver rbi single and the rockies
retake the lead
4-3 line drive center field that ball
was smoked rogers to second
so the rbi single by brendan and a base
hit for fuentes
grab ball headed to second base hassan
kim will fire to first for the out that
ends the inning rockies get one on a
couple of hits but they also leave a
pair
two outs and fam
at first base fernando one for two of
the home run
lined to left field and that's going to
get down
fam's going to run the bases he's being
waved around third head at home
throw home they'll be none and the
padres have tied it up fernando tatis
junior driving in the run tied up four
to four
lie the other way to the gap in right
center field that'll one hop the wall
here comes fernando around he'll score
as the padres take the 5-4 lead against
kyle freeland in the fourth inning elias
diaz against the lefty blake snell this
ball crossed take a good look you won't
see it for long
second big fly of the year for elias
diaz
he caught that out front
base hit rockies take a 6'5 lead
it's the topiadazza show of the month of
june 1-0 to trevor who has an rbi double
he swings and sends one down the right
field line that's a fair ball and will
roll into the corner dazza is flying he
taps third he's gonna go for the plate
here comes the throw now nearly in time
as he slides across and swipes it with
the left hand
rbi double for story and the rockies
lead seven to five and that is the day
for blake snell
nice strike three call 99 freezing
rogers and ending the inning rockies get
three more though here in the fourth
inning and they take a 7-5 lead to the
fifth jay gronalworth going to lead it
off he came into the game as part of a
double switch
turns on this and it's a fly ball to
deep right feel back goes daza
home run for jay cronenworth leads off
the sixth inning padres back within a
run it's down seven to six rockies
one two
swung on and missed stevenson gets the
strikeout for the first half of the
sixth
swing and a miss got him on a curveball
so after the homer robert has come back
with two strikeouts right-hander tyler
kinley making appearance number 27
strike three on grisham tyler kinley
right there to ring up grisham out
number two in the seventh
and he swings and sends a one hopper to
the right side rogers at the edge of the
outfield grass has it throws onto first
and a good inning for tyler kinley
retiring the side in order it'll leave
it up to rymel tapia to see if he could
give carlos cestevez a little more
cushion pitcher johnson to the
left-handed swinging tapia who goes the
opposite way
and gets a base hit his third hit
of the day
on the ground kind of a grass cutter out
to shore tatisse
to the bag its second awkwardly gets him
out
got over there and got the foot on the
bag to retire toppy who's coming in so
six unassisted on the fourth shot at
second base carlos stevens into the game
trying to finish it off aces loaded with
one out now for trent grisham
fly ball headed to deep left center
field over his center fielder hanson
tagging it third is fam
he will score and the padres
have tied it up seven to seven in the
ninth inning winning run in scoring
position with nobody out
base hit up the middle this will win it
story cruising home
and the rockies walk off the padres and
they sweep them
they wanted a mess with blackman and
chuck made him pay
8-7 colorado